dear men understand though this is true
the world is in haste and it approaches
the end because it is ever worldly the
longer it lasts the worse it becomes and
so it must necessarily greatly worsen
before the coming of Antichrist because
of the sins of the people and indeed it
will become then fearful and terrible
throughout the world understand also
completely that the devil has deceived
this people too much and that there has
been little faith among men though they
speak fair words and too many crimes
have gone unchecked in the land and
there were never many men who considered
what steps should be taken as earnestly
as one ought to do but each day one
added evil to evil and committed crime
and much injustice altogether too widely
throughout all this nation and also we
have for that reason endured many
injuries and insults and if we shall
look for any remedy then we must deserve
better of God than we have done hitherto
because with great deservings we have
earned the miseries which rely upon us
and with very great deservings we must
obtain the remedy at the hand of God if
henceforth things shall become better
though we know very well that a very
grave violation will require a great
remedy and that a very great fire much
water if a man wishes to extinguish the
fire at all and great is the need for
every man that he should henceforth
earnestly respect God's law and pay
God's dues rightly among heathen peoples
no one would dare to withhold little or
much of that which is ordained for the
honor of false gods and everywhere we
withhold God's Jews altogether too often
and among heathen peoples no one dare
lesson within or without the temple any
of the things which are brought for the
false gods and proffered as gifts and we
have entirely de spoiled the house of
God inside and outside and the servants
of God are everywhere deprived of honor
and protection and among heathen people
no one would dare ill-treat the servants
of the false gods in any way as now one
does to the servants of God
too widely where Christian men ought to
honor God's law and protect God's
servants but it is true what I say there
is need for that remedy because the
rights of God have now for a long time
been neglected throughout this nation
and every region and the laws of the
people have deteriorated in every region
and the laws of the people have
deteriorated altogether too often since
Edgar died and holy places are
everywhere to open to attack and the
houses of God are too completely
deprived of ancient rites and stripped
within of all that is fitting and
religious orders have now for a long
time being greatly despised and widows
of force to marry on righteously and to
many men are reduced to poverty that
poor men are wretchedly deceived and
cruelly cheated and wholly innocent sold
out of this land far and wide into the
possession of foreigners and through
cruel injustice children in the cradle
are enslaved for petty theft widely
throughout this nation and the rights of
freemen suppressed and the rights of
thralls curtailed and the rights of
charity neglected and to speak most
briefly God's laws are hated and his
commands despised
and therefore through the anger of God
we all suffer frequent insults let him
acknowledge it who may and this harm
will become common though one may not
think so to all this nation unless God
will save us for it is evident and
played in all our lives that we have
previously sinned more often than we
have improved and therefore much is
attacking the people things have not
prospered now for a long time at home or
beyond our land but there has been
warfare and famine burning and bloodshed
in every district time and again and
theft and murder plague and pestilence
Moraine and disease malice and hate and
plundering of robbers have harmed us
very severely and excessive levies of
tribute have greatly afflicted us and
bad weather has very often caused bad
harvests because in this country there
has been as it may seem for many years
now many crimes and unstable loyalties
everywhere among men
[Music]
now very often the Kingsmen gives
protection to a Kingsman no more than to
a stranger neither a father-to-son nor
at times a son to his own father nor a
brother to another brother nor has
anyone of us arranged his life as he
should
neither the clergy according to their
vows nor the laity according to the law
but altogether too often we make our
desires into laws for us and we've kept
neither the teachings nor the laws of
God nor of men as we should know does
anyone in a loyal Manor think on anyone
else as rightly as he should but almost
everyone is deceived and injured another
by word indeed and especially family
almost everyone stubs another from
behind in shameful attack let him do
more if he may for here in the country
there are great betrayals of trust in
respect of God and in respect of men and
also here in the land are many traitors
in various ways and it is the greatest
betrayal of all in the world that a man
should betray the soul of his Lord and
it is also a great betrayal in the world
that a man should betray his Lord to
death or drive him into exile while he
lives and both have happened in this
land
Edward was betrayed and afterwards
killed and after laughs burned and too
many godparents and God children have
been killed widely throughout this
nation in addition to far too many other
innocent people have been slain far too
often in every district and far too many
holy places have declined because some
men have been placed in them as they
should never have been if one wish to
show respect in God's sanctuary of far
too many Christian people have been sold
out of this land now all the time and
all this is hateful to God
let him believe it who will and it is
shameful to speak of that which happens
too widely and is too terrible too
what too many do often who commit that
crime who contribute together and buy a
woman as a common purchase and with that
one woman practice abomination one after
another and each after another most like
dogs that have no regard for filth and
afterwards they sell for a price into
the possession of enemies that creature
of God and his own purchase that he
daily bought also we know well where
that wretched crime has occurred that a
father has sold his son for a price and
the son his mother and one brother has
sold another into the possession of
strangers and all these are monstrous
and terrible deeds let him understand
who will and yet what harms this nation
is greater and also more widespread many
are forced sworn and utterly perjured
and pledges have broken time and again
and is obvious in this nation that the
anger of God violently oppresses us let
him perceive it who can and lo how may a
greater shame fall on men through the
anger of God then it frequently does on
us for our own deeds though any thrall
runs away from his Lord and turns from
the Christian to the Viking life and
after that happens that an armed
conflict takes place between the Thane
and the thrall if the thrall kills the
thane know where gild is payable to all
of his kindred and if the thane kills
the thrall whom he owned beforehand he
pays the waggled to a Thane very
loathsome laws and shameful exactions
are common among us because of the anger
of God let him understand it who can
and many misfortunes befall this nation
time and again things have not prospered
now for a long time at home or beyond
our land but in every region there has
been warfare and hatred time and again
and the English have been for a long
time now wholly without victory and to
greatly disheartened through the anger
of God and the Vikings are so strong by
the consent of God that often in battle
one puts to flight 10 and sometimes less
sometimes more all because of our sins
and often 10 or 12 one after another
shamefully insults the thanes wife and
sometimes his daughter or near Kings
woman while he looks on who before that
happened thought himself brave and
strong and manly enough and offered a
thrall binds very fast
the Thane or previously was his Lord and
makes him into a thrall through the
anger of God alas for the wretchedness
and alas for the greater humiliation
which the English now India holy through
the anger of God often to likings or
sometimes 3dr the muster of the
Christian men from coast to coast out
from the myths of this nation huddled
together as is a great shame to us all
if we could really and rightly perceive
it but all the insulting which we often
endure we required by honoring those who
insult us we pay them continually and
they humiliate us daily they ravage and
they burn they plunder and steal and
carry off to their fleet and lo what
other thing is clear and evident in all
these events if not the anger of God
also it is no Marvel although misfortune
befall us because we know full well that
for many years now men have too often
not cared what they did in word or deed
but this nation has become as it may
appear very corrupted by manifold sins
and by many crimes by murder and evil
deeds by avarice greed by stealing and
robbery by the barter of men in pagan
abuses by betrayals and trickeries by
attacks on kinsmen and man sought us by
violation of holy orders and breaches of
divine law by incest and various
fornications and also widely as we said
before by the breaking of oaths and of
pledges and by various lies many more
than there should be a lost and purge it
and the disregarding of church feasts
and fasts happens widely time and again
and also there are in the land
degenerate apostates and cruel
persecutors of the church and first
tyrants altogether too many and
everywhere despises of divine laws and
Christian customs and foolish mockers
everywhere in the nation very often are
those things which God messengers
command and most of all those things
which should always by right pertain to
God's law and therefore it has now
become far and wide as a very evil
custom that men are now more ashamed for
good deeds than for evil deeds because
too often one spurns good deeds with
division and reviles god-fearing men
altogether too much
and most of all 1r approves and treats
with scorn altogether too often those
who love the right and have an or of God
in any matter and because people act in
this manner that they derive all that
they should praise and hate too much
what they should love by this means one
brings all too many into wicked thought
and into crime so they are not ashamed
even though they sinned greatly and
commit them against God himself with all
but because of vain attacks they are
ashamed to a toll for their crimes as
the penitential books teach like those
foolish men who for their pride will not
protect themselves from harm until they
cannot however much they wish it here
too many in the land as it may appear
are grievously stained by the stains of
sin here our murderous and Slayers of
kin and killers of priests and
persecutors of monasteries and here are
per juris and contrived errs of murder
and here harlots and child murderers and
many foul adulterous [ __ ] mongers and
here our wizards and witches and here
our plunderers and and robbers and
thieves and to speak most briefly a
countless number of all crimes and foul
deeds and it does not shame us at all in
respect of that but it greatly puts us
to shame that we begin the penance as
the books teach and that is evident in
this wretched sinful people and it does
not shame us at all in respect of that
but it greatly puts us to shame that we
begin the penance as the books teach and
that is evident in this wretched sinful
people
alas many may easily think of much
besides this which one man alone might
not quickly examine so wretchedly it
happens now all the time
widely throughout this nation and indeed
let each one earnestly examine himself
and let him not delay all too long but
low in the name of God let us do as is
needful for us protect ourselves as we
may most earnestly lest we all perish
together
there was a chronicler called Gilda's in
the time of the Britons who wrote about
their misdeeds how they by their sins
and good God so excessively that he at
last allowed the army of Englishmen to
conquer their homeland to destroy
entirely the season strength of the
Britons and that happened as he foretold
by the plundering by powerful men and
the covetousness of ill-gotten gains by
the lawlessness of the people and by bad
judgments in legal cases by the
slackness of bishops and by the base
cowardice of gods and messengers who all
too often kept silent about the truth
and mumbled with their jaws where they
should have called out also but a foul
pride of the people and by gluttony and
by manifold sins they destroy their
native land themselves perished but let
us do as there is need for us to do be
warned by such things what I say is true
we know of worse deeds among the English
then we heard anywhere among the Britons
and therefore there is great need for us
to give thought about ourselves and to
intercede earnestly with God himself and
let us do as there is need for us to do
turn to good and in some part renounce
evil and very earnestly atone for what
we have transgressed
and let us love God and follow God's
laws and very earnestly perform that
which we or those were our sponsors of
baptism promised when we received
baptism and let us order our words and
deeds rightly and earnestly cleanse our
thoughts and carefully honor Oh thump
ledge and maintain some loyalty among us
without evil practice and let us often
reflect on the great judgment to which
we all shall come and earnestly save
ourselves from the surging fire of
hellish torment and earn for ourselves
the glories and the joys which God has
prepared for those who do his will in
the world may God help us our men
[Music]